Vous savez, quand je suis arrivée
au camp j'avais 15 ans.
J'avais un plan dans la tête en disant :
"Je peux pas mourir à 15 ans, il faut que je revienne."
C'était une idée fixe.
Il y a quelques jours, j'ai rencontré Esther Senot.
À tout juste 15 ans, Esther Senot a été déportée
vers le camp de concentration et d'extermination
d'Auschwitz-Birkenau, pendant la Seconde Guerremondiale.
Et elle a perdu une grande partie de
sa famille dans ces camps de la mort.
Elle est l'une des rares survivantes de ces camps et
parmi les dernières personnes à pouvoir encore témoigner.
Alors, vous allez le voir : l'histoire d'Esther Senot est à la fois unique par son intensité et ses multiples rebondissements,
mais elle est aussi le reflet d'un moment de l'histoire,
par le prisme de la vie d'une jeune fille, juive, en France, dans les années 40.
Esther Senot est née en Pologne en 1928 sous le nom d'Esther Dzik. Elle est la sixièmeenfant d'une famille juive modeste,
qui, face àl'antisémitisme montant en Pologne,
décide de migrer vers la France,
étant perçue à l'époque comme le pays des droits de l'Homme.
En 1930, sa famille s'installe à
Paris, dans le quartier populaire de Belleville
où réside une importante communauté de juifspolonais.
À ce moment là, Esther a deux ans.
Neuf ans plus tard, lorsque la France déclare la guerre à l'Allemagne nazie, le 3 septembre 1939, Esther a 11 ans.
En mai 1940, les Allemandsenvahissent la France.
Et le 22 juin, l'armisticeest signé entre la France et l'Allemagne.
Le moissuivant, c'est le maréchal Pétain qui obtient les pleins pouvoirs et qui devient le chef de l'État français.
La France est alors divisée par une lignede démarcation :
au Nord, c'est la zone occupée par l'armée allemande,
et au Sud, c'est la zone libre qui est sous l'autorité
du gouvernement de Vichy, mené par le maréchalPétain.
Rapidement, des lois qui limitent leslibertés des juifs, sont votées en France.
Et dans un premier temps, ils doivent se faire recenser en tant que "juif",
pour que leurreligion apparaisse sur leurs papiers d'identité.
– Sur les papiers d'identité, ils mettaient un tampon rouge
où il y avait marqué "juif" dessus.
–C'était le cas de votre famille ?
– Bien sûr. Après, on nous areproché d'avoir été au recensement,
mais vous savez, nous on était tellement respectueux en tant qu'étrangers, on était tellement respectueux des lois françaises,
dès l'instant où c'était la police française qui nous convoquait, on a fait confiance.
Dans les mois qui suivent, plusieurs lois vont êtrevotées, avec notamment :
l'interdiction pour les juifsd'exercer certains métiers,
l'obligation de porter l'étoile jaune,
l'obligation de ne voyager que dansla dernière rame de métro,
ou encore l'interdiction de fréquenter les parcs, les cinémas, les théâtresou encore les bibliothèques.
C'est en mai 1941 qu'a lieu un tournant, avec la "rafle du billet vert". C'est la première arrestation massive de juifs à Paris,
suite àlaquelle, du côté d'Esther, l'un de ses frères
est déporté après avoir été convoqué au commissariat.
Les mois suivants, les rafles vont se multiplier dans le pays,
jusqu'au 16 juillet 1942 : jour de la "rafle du Vel d'Hiv" à Paris.
Quelques temps après donc, il y avait des bruits quicouraient dans le quartier disant qu'il allait y avoir des rafles.
Alors là, le 16 juillet au matin,
il y a eu un grand branle-bas. On a entendu des cris.
Et finalement on a entendumonter dans les escaliers,
on a entendu frapper aux portes.
Il y a des gens qui ne voulaient pasouvrir,
ils défonçaient les portes à coups de matraqueen disant :
"Préparez un petitbagage et vous vous rassemblez en bas dans la rue."
Alors Esther assiste avec le restede sa famille
à l'arrestation de leurs voisins, arrêtés parce que juifs,
sans vraiment comprendre cequ'il se passe.
Une fois le calme revenu dans lequartier,
et la police ayant visiblement oubliéd'arrêter la famille d'Esther,
sa mère, très inquiète, demande à Esther et à sa soeurFanny
d'aller chacune voir si leurs proches sont bien en sécurité
dans le reste de Paris.
Estherpart seule depuis Belleville vers la place de la République
où habitent sa belle-sœur et son neveu,
qui, heureusement, n'ont pas été arrêtés.
Mais le lendemain matin en rentrant chezelle, Esther découvre que son appartement est vide et mis sous scellé.
Elle ne peut donc pas y entrer, sa famille n'est plus présente.
Elle est seule.
Alors, ils ont dû se rendre compte au commissariat qu'ils avaient oublié de passer chez nous,
et dans ce laps de temps où je suis partie avec ma sœur,
ils sont venus arrêter mes parents et mon petit frère qui avait onze ans.
Entre le 16 et le 17 juillet1942, la police française, sur ordre des autoritésallemandes, arrête plus de 13 000 juifs à Paris,
dont plus de 4 000 enfants.
La plupart sont emmenés au Vélodrome d'Hiver
avant d'êtredéportés vers le camp d'Auschwitz,
où la majorité d'entre eux sera exterminée.
Après l'arrestation de sa famille, Esther tente de retourner
place dela République pour retrouver sa belle-sœur,
or,entre-temps, sa belle-sœur s'est enfuie.
À 14 ans, Esther est donc seule à Paris.
Et désespérée, elle explique sa situation à la gardienne de l'immeuble qui décide de l'héberger pour quelques jours.
Alors finalement, elle m'a fait rentrer dans sa loge
et elle m'a gardée une quinzaine de jours.
Alors vous savez en prenant des risques, parceque les gens
qui essayaient de sauver des juifs risquaient de se faire arrêter.
Vous savez, il y avait deux France : ceux qui aidaient et ceux qui dénonçaient.
La gardienne réussit finalement à trouver un passeur
qui est censé aider Esther à traverserla ligne de démarcation,
pour rejoindre son frère à Pau, dans le Sud, en zone libre.
Esther prend donc le train la boule au ventre,
par crainte d'être repérée et une fois arrivée à Bordeaux,
le passeur va finalement l'abandonner.
Elle décide alors de passer seule la ligne de démarcation,
en traversant, en pleine nuit, la forêt des Landes,
et ce malgré l'importante présence militaire.
J'ai attendu vers dix heures et demi, il commençait à faire nuit,
alors je suis sortie, et puis vous savez à 14 ans oncourt vite,
alors j'ai réussi à rentrer dans cetteforêt
où j'ai effectivement trouvé cette ligne dechemin de fer,
et j'ai commencé à longer pendantdes heures,
et puis quand il a commencé à fairenuit noire,
vous savez, j'ai commencé à paniquer.
Mais alors là, j'étais complètement paniquée, je tournais en rond, j'avais l'impression que tous lesbruits se répercutaient,
et puis vous savez,nous notre littérature quand on était à Paris,
c'était des livres contes et légendes,
quand on était perdu dans une forêt, on risquait
de se faire dévorer par des bêtes fauves,
vous savez tout ce qui peut vous passer par la tête
quand vous êtes complètement paniquée,
et j'ai tourné en rond comme ça toute la nuit.
Le lendemain matin, aprèsplus de 48 heures sans manger,
Esther réalisefinalement qu'elle a réussi à passer en zone libre,
elle rejoint son frère à Pau, avec quielle va rester
quelques mois jusqu'à la fin del'année 1942.
Et en novembre 1942, le frèred'Esther s'engage dans les Forces Françaises Libres :
des unités formées par le Général deGaulle
pour combattre le régime autoritaire deVichy en France.
Esther va alors décider de rentrerà Paris
dans l'espoir de retrouver sa famille,
mais malheureusement, quand elle arrive à Paris,
elle réalise que sa famille n'est toujours pas présente.
Les mois suivants, Esther doit se débrouillerseule
dans la capitale jusqu'à un soir d'août 1943,
où, en sortant du métro Saint-Paul,
trois policierslui demandent ses papiers.
Esther refuse d'abord de leur donner son adresse et son nom,
qui a uneconsonance étrangère,
et les policiers l'emmènentalors au commissariat.
Et puis là au bout d'unmoment, à force d'être un peu secouée,
violemment, j'ai fini par donner mon nom.
Avec le recensement, les policiers constatent qu'Esther Dzik
est juiveet dès le lendemain elle est conduite à Drancy,
un camp de transit dans lequel les juifs
sontenfermés quelques jours avant d'être déportés.
– Qu'est ce que vous ressentez à ce moment là ?
C'est de la peur j'imagine ?
– Non, ça n'a pas été de la peur, ça a été un soulagement.
Parce que nous, notre hantise c'était de se faire arrêter.
Alors finalement ça a été un soulagement en disant : "Ben ça y est, j'ai fini de traîner à la galère, je vais retrouver mes parents".
Alors pour moi ça a été un soulagement.
Après son arrestation, Esther passe quelques jours à Drancy
où elle rencontre Marie, une jeune femme qui a cinq ans de plus,
c'est le début d'une amitié et de deux destins liés à jamais.
Quelques jours plustard,
le 2 septembre 1943, un millier de juifs dont
Esther et son amie Marie
sont amenés depuis Drancyvers la gare de Bobigny,
où stationnent sur placedes trains à bestiaux.
Quand on a vu ce train...
d'unelongueur...
J'ai dit : "Ça ne doit pas être pour nous,
c’est des wagons à bestiaux",
il y a certainement un autre train qui va venir.
Bah non, c’était pour nous.
Alors là, ils nous ont propulsés dans ceswagons.
Ce jour-là, Esther est emmenée vers le campd'Auschwitz-Birkenau en Pologne
par le 59e convoide ce type.
Un convoi dont elle et sonamie Marie
seront les deux seules femmes à survivreau camp.
Dans ce voyage, vous l'imaginez,
lesconditions sont absolument terribles.
Et puis dansles wagons à bestiaux,
il y avait juste une petitelucarne grillagée.
Il n'y avait pas d'air.
Alorsils nous ont mis un seau avec de l'eau
et ils nous ont mis un tonneau pour les besoins hygiéniques.
Et ils ont fermé les portes.
Ils ont verrouillé les portes, et le train est parti.
Alors, évidemment, vous raconter
ce qui s'est passé dans ce train pendant troisjours...
Le premier jour il y avait toutes
ces personnes âgées qui tombaient par terre...
On se resserrait encore davantage pour leur laisser
de la place pour qu’ils puissent s’asseoir...
Les bébés qui commençaient à hurler...
enfin les enfantsqui hurlaient...
Ça a été quelque chose d'effroyable, une nuit effroyable...
Alors évidemment, le premier jour,
le seau a été vidé, parce qu’on avait soif.
Puis la deuxième nuit, le tonneau...
le tonneau pour les besoins s’est renversé.
Et on a fini le voyage là-dedans, alors vous voyez
dans quel état on est arrivés quand le train s’est arrêté.
Après 3 jours de voyage sans fin,
le train s’arrête le 4 septembre 1943.
Esther est arrivée au camp d’Auschwitz-Birkenau.
C’est à la fois un camp de concentration,
donc un camp de travail mais aussi un camp d’extermination,
c’est-à-dire un camp destiné à tuer massivement
les personnes qui y sont présentes.
Avant d'entrer dans le camp, les soldats allemands demandent
aux personnes âgées, aux enfants et aux femmesfatiguées
de monter dans des camions.
Et puis, ilsfont défiler les personnes restantes une par une
et les séparent en deux files.
106 femmes dont EstherSennot et Marie
sont alors sélectionnées pourrentrer travailler au camp.
Et quand on est arrivées devant la porte d'entrée,
qui s'est ouverte...
Alors on ne voyait rien, il y avait une fumée épaisse...
Puis des odeurs...
qu'on n'arrivait pas à définir.
Alors on a commencé à marcher
pour entrer dansle camp... et puis là,
on a vu le long de l’allée principale
des cadavres sur le côté.
De loin, on voyait des chiens avec les kapos
qui couraient après des femmes qui étaient
des squelettes ambulants.
Alors on se demandait dans quelenfer on était entrées.
Effectivement, on voyaitces espèces de fumée qui sortaient.
Alors commeon nous avait parlé
d'un camp de travail, j'ai dit :
"C'est peut-être un truc industriel".
Enfin, voussavez, on ne savait pas du tout où on était.
On a fini par leur demander :
"Mais les personnes qui sont montées dans lescamions,
quand est-ce qu'on va les retrouver ?"
Alors, ils nous ont dit :
"Ne vous faites pas d'illusions, lesfumées que vous voyez
c’est pas des trucs industriels,
c’est les chambres à gaz".
Alors les chambres à gaz, on n’avait jamais entendu
parler de ça, encore moins des fours crématoires.
Alors on s'est dit : "Mais ce n’est pas possible,
qu’est-ce que c’est que ce truc-là ?"
Alors finalement...
avec Marie on s’est dit : "Ils nous racontent
ça pour nous faire peur, ce n'est pas possible".
Comment voulez-vous que deux heures aprèsnotre arrivée
ils aient pu tuer 650 personnes commeça
en si peu de temps ?
On n'y croyait pas.
Très vite, Esther est entièrement rasée
et on va lui tatouer un numéro:
le numéro 5-8-3-1-9 directement sur le bras.
On a été rasées entièrement.
Et ensuite on a été tatouéessur le bras.
Ils nous ont tatoué un numéro en nous en disant
que maintenant nous n'avions plus d'identité
et que dèsl'instant où l'on était interpellé dans le camp,
il fallait donner notre numéro en allemand.
Alors évidemment, quand
vous ne parlez pas l'allemand...
Se rappeler un numéro à cinq chiffres ce n'est pas évident.
Et après quelques jours, Esther comprend
que très peu sortiront vivants dece camp.
Moi, vous savez, quand je suis arrivée au camp, j'avais 15 ans.
J’avais un plan dans la tête en me disant :
"Je ne peux pas mourir à 15 ans, il faut que je revienne".
C’était une idée fixe.
À Auschwitz-Birkenau, les conditions de vie sont terribles.
Chaque matin, un appel a lieupour décompter les décès
qui sont survenus durant la nuit.
Cet appel dure parfois des heures.
Lescorps sont alignés devant les baraques,
où les déportés dorment entassés
sur des planches chaque soir.
Et après l'appel du matin,
Esther doittravailler de force,
des travaux difficilementsupportables
et complètement inhumains.
Et en fin de journée, les déportés doivent
quotidiennement seplier à une sélection,
pendant laquelle les nazis
séparent d'un côté
les personnes qu'ils considèrent
comme encore aptes à travailler,
et de l'autre côté, les personnes jugées trop faibles
et qui sont doncenvoyées directement
vers les fours crématoires.
Alors il y avait toujours ces deux files,
et ils poussaient le sadisme parce qu’un jour
c’était la file de droite qui était envoyée aux crématoires,
et le lendemain c’était la file de gauche.
Alors vous savez, on avait toujours l’angoisse quand on revenait au camp, de se dire dans quelle file on va être.
Dans le camp, les déportées ne sont quasiment pas nourries.
Elles partagent en fait une gamelle, dans laquelleles chefs
des blocs servent de la soupe,
qu'elles doivent manger sans cuillère.
De loin on voyait les kapos, enfin tout le personnel
qui avait desfonctions dans le camp,
en train de ricaner en disant :
"Regardez, on vous avait dit que les juifs
ce n'étaient pas des êtres humains,
regardez, ils se comportent
commedes chiens."
Quand il y avait un peu de soupe
dans le fond du tonneau,
elles le renversaient par terre.
Alors vous avez des centaines de femmes qui se couchaient
pour essayer de récupérer quelque chose.
En dehors des travaux forcés,
en dehors de tous les sévices qu’on pouvait subir,
elles faisaient exprès d’essayer
de nous déshumaniser le plus possible.
Enfin, ça a été une période épouvantable et puis vous savez,
il y a tellement de choses qu'on peut pas raconter...
Vous savez quand j’y pense maintenant,
je me dis : "Ce n’est pas possible
qu’ils aient pu faire les expériences
qu’ils ont faites sur les gens".
Un soir de l’hiver 1943, alors qu’Esther est aux latrines,
une jeune femme l’interpelle.
et cette jeunefemme, et bien,
c'est sa sœur aînée Fanny.
Moi je ne l'ai pas reconnue, c'est elle qui m'a reconnue...
Quand elle m'a vue...
elle est venue vers moi,
elle m’a lancé une paire de claques
en me disant :
“Je pensais que toi au moins tu aurais réchappé”.
Elle n'a pasvoulu comprendre et puis après,
évidemment, elle m'aprise dans ses bras.
ça a été des retrouvailles on ne peut plus pénibles.
Fanny, qui était arrivée au camp 10 mois plus tôt,
est donc déjà très faible,
et son état ne fait qu’empirer.
C’est quelques mois plus tard, en mars ou en avril 1944,
qu’Esther parle pour la dernière fois avec sa sœur dans le Revier,
un baraquement destiné aux prisonniers malades.
Ma sœur était couchée dans le Revier.
Alors je lui dis : "Fanny, tu ne peux pas rester là,
tu te rends compte, tu sais très bien ce qu’il va arriver".
Elle m'a dit : “Ecoute, je n’en peux plus, c’est fini”.
Elle m'a dit : "La seule chose que je regrette,
c’est de ne pas être montée dans les camions en arrivant,
parce qu’elle dit j’ai essayé de tenir jusqu’au bout mais...
Elle m'a dit : "C’est fini, laisse-moi tranquille,
j’en peux plus, c’est fini pour moi".
Et c’est là qu’elle m’a prise dans ses bras, et elle m’a dit :
"Écoute, toi t’es jeune encore, t’as l’air de tenir le coup.
La guerre va bientôt finir. Essaie de tenir le coup
le plus longtemps possible,
si t’as une chance de revenir, promets-moi de raconter
ce qui nous est arrivé qu’on ne soit pas les oubliés de l’Histoire.
Finalement après il a fallu que
je reprenne les rangs pour aller travailler,
quand je suis revenue le soir elle n’était plus là.
Le 18 janvier 1945, alors que l'Allemagnenazie
est au bord de la défaite militaire,
et queles troupes russes s'approchent d'Auschwitz,
lecamp est évacué et les prisonniers,
très affaiblis, sont transférés, durant des jours,
à pied et dansun froid glacial, vers d'autres camps.
Cette marche, c'est ce que l'on appelle :
"Les marches de la mort".
Sitôt qu’il y en avait une qui sortait des rangs
ou qui s’écroulait, le SS avec son pistolet
lui mettait une balle dans la nuque.
Vous savez, on en a laissé du monde
sur le bord de la route.
Et après plusieursjours de marche,
Esther et Marie arrivent d'aborden Allemagne,
dans le camp de concentration de
Bergen-Belsen.
Et alors là, les baraques étaient grandes ouvertes
pleines de cadavres.
Il y en avait même jusque devant les portes.
Impossible de rentrer dans les baraques.
C'était un cimetière à ciel ouvert.
Après Bergen-Belsen, Esther transite par plusieurs camps,
jusqu’à celui de Mauthausen, en Autriche.
Et sur place, Esther est tout simplement à bout de forces.
Son état de santé est en fait catastrophique.
Elle ne pèse plus que 32 kg et elle a,
au-delà de ça, letyphus,
une maladie infectieuse très grave.
Et le 5 mai 1945, j'étais toujours avec Marie,
on ne s’est jamais quittées...
et le 5 mai 1945 on a eu l’appel le matin.
Alors là j’ai dit à Marie :
"Ecoute, laisse-moi tranquille je ne sors pas à l’appel".
J’en pouvais plus, j’étais vraiment arrivée au bout du rouleau,
parce que dans mon esprit je me suis dit :
"Ils vont encoretrouver un train ou ils vont nous fusiller".
Parceque là, on sentait vraiment que c'était fini.
C'était vraiment la fin de la guerre.
Alors je lui dis : "C’est terminé, j’en peux plus, laisse-moi tranquille". Elle m’a sortie de force à l’appel.
Donc on a eu l’appel, ça a été vite fait,
et puis on est retournées dans les baraques.
Et puis, en début d'après-midi, on est ressorties dans la cour,
et on a vu le drapeau blanc sur la forteresse du camp.
On a vu descendre les premiers prisonniers,
vous savez avec leurs pyjamas rayés,
qui descendaient encourant vers nos baraques en nous disant :
"Les Allemands ont ouvert les portes. Ils ont dit qu'ilsallaient revenir, qu’ils allaient tuer tout le monde.
Ne restez pas dans les baraques. Partez.
Parce quelorsqu'ils vont revenir ils vont faire un massacre".
Alors il nous dit : “Nous on s’en va,
si vous voulez, vous nous suivez, mais on ne vous attend pas.”
Alors dans l’état où on était,
moi déjà le matin je pouvais plus me lever,
et Marie, elle me dit : “Qu’est-ce qu’on fait ?”. Alors je lui dis : “Qu’est-ce que tu veux que je fasse ? Je ne tiens pas debout”.
Alors on s’est consultées avec une dizaine de femmes,
dans l’état où on était, enfin bon
on tenait quand même un peu sur nos jambes,
et on a décidé de sortir, on est parties.
Après plusieurs rebondissements, Estheret Marie sont finalement rapatriées en France le25 mai 1945
par un avion militaire américain.
Ellessont amenées directement à l'hôtel Lutetia à Paris,
où les déportés sont accueillis et où les familles
affluent dans l'espoir de retrouver leurs proches.
Malheureusement, personne ne viendra récupérer Esther.
Après la guerre, Esther a beaucoupde difficultés
à revenir à une vie normale,
etce pendant de très nombreuses années.
Elle dortsur le sol car elle n'arrive plus à dormir dansun lit.
Et au-delà de ça, elle fait notamment
descauchemars en permanence.
Et par ailleurs, commebeaucoup de déportés,
Esther va vraiment souffrir
de la difficulté à raconter ce qu'elle a vécudans les camps.
Alors finalement, les genssont arrivés vers nous
en nous disant : "Qu'est-ce qu’il vous est arrivé ?"
Alors on a commencé à vouloir leur raconter
ce qu'il nous était arrivé.
Alors il nous ont regardé,
en nous disant : "Mais vous êtes devenues folles,
comment ça se fait que vous propagiez des histoires pareilles ?!
C'est pas vrai, c’est n’importe quoi."
Et puis finalement, je me souviens d'un
monsieur qui m'a dit :
"Mais vous êtes revenus si peu nombreux, qu'est-ce que vous avez fait vouspour revenir et par les autres ?"
Alors finalement, on a pratiquement été culpabilisés d'être dessurvivants.
Finalement après des années très difficiles,
une tentative de suicide et un séjour de
quelques mois dans un hôpital psychiatrique,
Esther réussit finalement à trouver un travail
et àreconstruire étape par étape, petit à petit, sa vie.
Aujourd'hui, alors qu'Esther Senot est âgée de93 ans,
elle continue à témoigner régulièrement
et ce, pour que les jeunes générations
n'oublient pas cette période sombre del'histoire.
– Votre courage, il est évidemment danscette période,
pendant la guerre et ce que vousavez vécu
et la façon dont vous vous en êtes sortie,
évidemment votre courage, il est ici.
Mais votre courage il est aussi dans le fait d’en parler
encore aujourd'hui, et d’en parler malgré les traumatismes,
malgré ce que vous avez vécu, pourquoi est-ce que c’est
aussi important pour vous d’en parler aujourd’hui ?
– J'avais toujours la promesse dema sœur.
et puis de voir... Vous savez, ce qui a été le plus pénible,
c’était de voir l’indifférence des gens.
Comme si on n'avait jamais existé.
Finalement on avait l’impression qu’on dérangeait.
Et je crois que c'était plus difficile à supporterça.
Après un entretien de près de 2h,
j’ai demandé à Esther Senot
si elle avait un message à faire passer
aux personnes qui regarderont cette vidéo.
Je vous laisse découvrir sa réponse.
La chance qu’ils ont c’est de vivre
dans un pays libre et démocratique,
et qu’ils fassent tout leur possible,
vu les évènements actuels, pour protéger cette démocratie,
parce que une démocratie c’est très fragile
dans les conditions actuelles.
Parce que, finalement, entre la démocratie et la dictature...
La dictature ça mène à Auschwitz.
En tout cas, c'était pour moi un réel honneur
de pouvoir échanger avec Esther Senot.
Elle vient d'ailleurs de publier un
livre qui fait le récit de son histoire,
avec l'aide de l'historienne Isabelle Ernot.
Sonlivre s'appelle : "La petite fille du passage Ronce".
Il est publié aux Editions Grasset,
donc ça vousintéresse, évidemment je vous le recommande,
et je vous mets le lien directement en description.
Et enfin, juste un petit mot pour vous remercier
parceque vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux à suivre
cette nouvelle chaîne principale "HugoDécrypte"
et ce, alors que c'est seulement
la quatrième vidéosur la chaîne.
On approche déjà des 200 000abonnés.
Du coup, si ce n'est pas encore le cas devotre côté, n'hésitez pas à vous abonner pour ne pas louper les vidéos suivantes.
Pourquoi pas aussià activer les notifications
pour nous souteniret nous encourager
à continuer ce travail gratuitdirectement sur YouTube.
Ecoutez, je crois que j'ai toutdit.
Prenez soin de vous, prenez soin de vos proches
et onse dit du coup à très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo.